thank you so much for being here we're
into London a YouTube space right now
yeah yeah yeah look how beautiful of
this lovely and grey and green and messy
yeah it looks like depressing yeah well
let's uh let's repress it Cheers
yeah my first ever Bloody Mary everybody
yay I'll buy ma juice but I'm already
dreading what that's gonna be like I
feel like I didn't make a good one how
much alcohol did you put in this is I'm
a lightweight
see you tomorrow if you had to get rid
of one finger which one I probably say
the the ring finger you know me always
well what is the point of the ring thing
because I mean you can't move by itself
you have to you know it's like tight you
know like the bones are fused with your
little finger so just get rid of that
one I mean you need your thumbs yes you
know and little fingers like you know if
you're trying to be posh you have to
yeah you know stick your little finger
out sho Hashi Wan do like hang loose
exactly yeah Shane but which would you
get rid of your actual like wedding ring
finger would you get rid of like the
right ring finger Oh like you give me a
choice of the bb-8 there which one do
you hate uh well I guess that one look
at the right hand because I mean that's
that's not the wedding ring one right
sadly she has no purpose in my life I
might get this removed off of the show
lab nope I have no use for this finger
would you like a finger oh I love doing
well this Emma blackery is the master of
accidentally saying that thing
accidentally lesbian like all the time I
think your hashtag is I'm sorry I I
don't know what I should tell the Hannah
Hart story now we'll save I guys wait
you have to tell us now because I asked
on Twitter and we'll get to the
questions later four questions for you
and then content flux of questions was
about the newest a question okay then
why do you think God made periods so
that we have an excuse to punch people
in the face once a month mm-hmm what I
like to think it's you know any time
socially acceptable just - yeah someone
else I'm on my period I was finding the
way yeah any time like
a man gives me any grief I just say
imagine if your dick bled for a whiie
yeah that's why I say imagine just going
to pee and then something there's just
blood splooshing out your dick how would
you feel every doubt might yeah there
are like four five guys in this room and
they're all like with their heads in
their hands right now just like I don't
want to be here yeah and they're like 10
minutes before this I just like I'm
gonna go Champa uncomfortableness in
this room right now it's still wet boobs
yeah lighten the mood
right like breastfeed though everyone
just perked up yeah how do you sleep
from whimsical hag Wow how do I sleep I
sleep on my side and apparently I snore
until the pounding of time I sleep you
fart you silently yeah I have heard okay
I want to mm-hm
you call the night toots everything I do
now so goddamn charming to make us make
that up but it sounds so scary well Emma
starting a second channel called night
toots it's just a live stream of her
sleeping on time so to challenge Emma
this is yours
yeah and sure okay and well there's
nothing here at all other than table and
chairs so you might be wondering what
are we about to embark on I don't want
to know do i yes you do okay is it
you've heard of the not my arms
challenge
yeah the I think today we're doing a
version of that called the no arms
challenge okay yeah as a youtuber social
media is something we rely on on a daily
basis so today we will be updating our
social media without the use of our arms
so we own our so what we're gonna be
doing is tweet with our feet right I
wish I called it tweet with your feet
yes it's a much cuter name than just
that no arms jelly
we'll think about that later I have
enough ever that's part of the challenge
we in no particular order
well the first order of business is that
we will be duct-taped with our arms
behind our back okay okay and then in no
particular order we have to mmm tweet
yeah send a tweet upload an Instagram
photo and create a vine wouldn't it with
our not with our no arm at all no elbows
no hands just nothing no shoulders but
anything else anything in the room you
can do you cannot coerce my crew into
tweeting for you okay
so Jack director Jack fair any of the
duct-tape sports
I hope duct taped a lot of people and
surprisingly none of it has been
sexually related at all okay just making
sure is how you like some people up on
websites I liked it I can't hear you
over the sound of this deaf day this is
also not the first time Jack Ferry has
duct-taped my hands what I think I
apologize in advance for the smell of my
feet I forgot to pack socks and the West
Sox minding on me way worse than yours
okay and you're allowed to sit if you
choose to okay we get to know each other
how this is you know this is the Sun
closer to evil come get ya you know
after my podcast no one ever talks to me
no I can't imagine what yeah it's a
weird thing I don't get it it's like you
tie your guests with duct tape hmm okay
there's a very limited time before grace
Helbig starts that with panic attack so
let's get seven two three
do what go okay my phone's already off
it's Twitter Instagram all right oh god
my eyes like hidden
oh no oh yes it is a great oh and here's
a spoiler alert I lose almost every I'm
cave oh let me go I've got this we're
all you foot-fetish weirdos out there
you're welcome it is oh wait look I'm
trying to follow you on vine get back
Thanks
oh this is No did you just know ready
now you can set up a shot with your
that's front facing camera I've got this
yeah no one's gonna understand this I
can't turn the front-facing camera on
this guy's Instagram okay
why isn't my vine working no I don't pay
in it to the Start screen except this is
an ad for the Windows Phone I'm going to
choose a nice filter for there oh you're
bish [ __ ] oh oh oh oh okay I hate this
game fire
oh wait that's part of the vine oh no
it's all black
it's all black the floor oh Jesus Christ
no submit you stupid deer currently um
doing this immediate open without feet
guys we're currently turn through social
media with our feet because I have the
triad with duct tape and grace is having
a freakout
okay I bind I find no I don't want to
watch Nash she was fine out of here
okay what did I only choose the vespa
filter
yeah that looks nice she wouldn't choose
oh I look horrific
okay I've got one more to do wait I am I
just tweeted I just read it I need to
Instagram good girl go go go
okay I got one more yeah yeah no no I
don't a search on it's true I don't care
about Marcus Butler's Instagram getting
without feet because grace is tied my
hands behind my back thanks grace you're
welcome Oh Fred face thing oh yes
oh come on yes yes yes no no yes
I think I win did you do it yeah duh no
three no it didn't upload yet where is
it oh did my yeah once once I don't know
I think I'm gonna tie I pretty sure that
if sweat is a factor here I definitely
am the winner
right now Mike I want to loose then here
yeah yeah you have some trouble with
that yeah who knew that feet are not
made for social media uh I tell you with
your feet and what did you tweet um a
picture between the photo how did you
turn the tweeter phone up my tweet was a
sjw lkx
that you remember that gets a ton of
retweets chicken please okay I'm gonna
actually give that one to you oh thanks
yeah you're welcome
oh no my photo looks like I sincerely
have been kidnapped in a room and I'm
taking my last or I don't like it it was
real bad the police are gonna be here
like any minute
great maybe they can take this tape off
of ya Emma blackery thank you so much
for being here on the podcast okay I
want to go listen to the full podcast go
over and search on iTunes for not too
deep with grace Helbig and go subscribe
to Emma here on YouTube it's very fun
I'm sincerely trying to get my hands
I just released me now you want goodbye
hi like my photos what do you think
Adele's fart smell like what do you do
with like how are you saying that with a
straight face because I'm inquisitive
about it